welcome welcome to your mom's house
[Music]
there's so much to get into wait we
gotta even get into our circumstance
we're doing the show today we're gonna
dance let's open this show crazy day
let's do it party fucking come over on
the side I'm sure take a shit
[Laughter]
[Music]
Tom Segura and Christina pussy
yeah I think that clip just turned my
whole day around yeah that's nice right
that might be my new favorite it's great
I don't know why the word diarrhea mix
you've always loved it so much yeah
so much you're very shit centered I
anything duty that's your wheelhouse
it's makes me laugh so much
you have very distinct wheelhouses that
make us laugh you know that's true
because I know if I ever want to make
you laugh around the house I'll be late
but did you fucking rip her tits off and
shit on her face and then jack off into
her eyes you stapler tits the desk and
look at ya see you gotta chuckle yeah
and then with me it's I've had diarrhea
but that's a real emergency I guess I've
had real emergencies I feel like I feel
like you can almost always find
somewhere to go that's not a parking lot
did I ever tell you the story about a
guy and once met at a party and he goes
one time I was in Thailand and I was in
a taxicab flanked by these two girls I
was trying to and he goes I had about a
diary and hit me so hard and we were
like in about like just traffic like a
red light nothing's gonna happen he goes
man I was holding it in holding it in
and just sweating and going through
waves and he's like eventually I just
willed it away
yeah that's what I've done I've willed
it away many times it's really rough
well you know what your body will your
body will fight if you're trying to get
laid
you're as a man as if diarrhea and
you're like there's a woman there I'm
trying to
yeah buddy we will stop this diarrhea
the toxic sickness yes so that you can
get laid
yes good priorities that's how the male
body and brain works damn it I've got
diarrhea the vulnerable but you're so
vulnerable you kind of have to announce
it like that his shit covered paper I'm
throwing this stuff in the dumpster that
Brody Stevens would you call him out
though I mean I feel like I'd have
empathy yeah like it's all right dude
just clean up just don't leave your
toilet paper out here okay no I mean
there's a couple things that he might
know that guy as a guy that's kind of
lingers and as always you know I mean
and a guy who was always like hey man
get the fuck it like you're the guys
always making customers feel
uncomfortable so it's like it's sound
almost familiar like hey man the fuck
are you doing wait do you know what that
sound is that's the sound of five
hundred emails pouring and telling us
that they've done public diarrhea yeah
yeah I know it's good I just heard the
pings right yeah I know it's gonna be
stinging next lit up all the diarrhea
stories it's gonna be there they are
every email
pouring in I've done it I'm shit behind
a dumpster I've shown the side of the
road yeah now I have had to remove so
badly I almost did I remember in college
sophomore year of college being in a
girl's dorm room who was down to do it
and she was like like just like get
comfortable and I felt the diarrhea like
strong no this is true I remember this
Renee I met her name I remember her name
was Mary Lynn all right yeah Mike my
friend yeah yeah it's Mary Lynn Rajskub
it was nice so but his name was Mary
name was Marilyn
and she so anyways I was like I got a
test in the morning I gotta get back and
I think she was like wow yeah you're
turning down yeah so anyways but I was
like I still gave her like a kiss and I
go back to my room and it's a like a
black pool like a it's like a rotten
just pool explosion and it's so much so
my suitemates like not my roommate that
the suite mates were like what the
fuck's going on in there cuz I could
hear the explosion yeah I'm like yeah I
know I hear I hear it every day was one
of the most horrendous shits
I've ever taken I remember the shits so
well and then I clean up and I'm like I
can't go back there now you know like I
said like cuz I basically what I wanted
to do was shit at her place and then try
to get laid but I knew no way I could
feel what way I know I could feel what
it was like if it would have been in one
thing if I'm like I kinda gotta shit
maybe I have been you can't but you can
never get away with shitting at a girl's
house and her not knowing yeah and I
don't know like that work then we're
gonna do it so it would be first time
doing it so shitty so the next day her
friend it was like oh my god she was
you're such a cool guy and I go what
like you know like most guys would have
just like jumped at the opportunity or
whatever but you're like whatever I have
to like she thought I was being risk
back full right of her of her and not
like not wanting to rush things
Wow isn't that crazy we we talk
ourselves and everything I was like I
just had to shit so bad that there was
no way I could do it right so but I was
like yeah no I know I am a nice guy I
just respect her self-respect like such
a good girl
yeah she's just really cool yeah that's
really funny
yeah you know on time man I was working
as like a PA and there this guy was
hosting some TV show and I was a PA and
I remember I had to shuttle him around
that day and we were in the Beverly some
Beverly Hills Mall right Beverly sir and
I remember he dude had to shit really
badly and I'll tell you it is off off
mic but we're going on this escalator
and I just saw it on his face like he
really had to shit he's a celebrity yeah
and I was like dude do you have to shit
like I just called it I was like do you
have to go shit or something and he's
like yeah like he didn't want to admit
that I was right and then I was like
toilets right there dude like just go
shit like I think he was trying to play
it cool around me he's your girl yeah
and you're attractive yeah that's why
yeah nobody doesn't matter like he could
be whatever like on his honeymoon and
like you still don't want to be like to
a girl like I got a shit bad not you
you're the exception
Doug Millard and his fiance came over a
gorgeous blonde hair yeah brown eye
looks pretty sweet girl yeah you sat at
the dinner table yeah you lived your ass
cheeks you farted and then you went I
got to take a shit and then I went shit
and then you shit yeah and not even buy
another bathroom away from us like the
kitchen bathroom that everyone uses and
we can hear you through the door like
you didn't even try to that's different
go down the hall that's different how's
it different well
first of all they're like family I mean
like Doug and and and Flynn have have
been on the road that's a different
level because I'm comfortable I'm saying
like a stranger like if it's like you
met someone and you're like hey I just
met you
oh yeah it's hard it's harder to be like
I got
shit you know yeah yeah mmm I've never
shit in in not a toilet
dude I'm saying like unless I've been in
Asia and like I've had to squat on the
on the ground
I cut legging Kyrgyzstan I had to do
that but you know I've always held it
now pee I peed everywhere I feel like
I've peed all over the earth I peed on
the side of the freeway no some wild
places yeah I mean I pissed on public
transportation haven't we all at some
point got this backstage that shows
where the bathroom was accessible yeah
yeah and I've done that multiple times a
piss in a trashcan backstage one time no
that thing like you're like you're up
yeah and by the way you're gonna be up
there 60 70 minutes and you're like I
got a piss real quick and they're like
oh there's no bathroom around here yeah
you're like well I got to go and they're
like well you know just hold it for an
hour and change oh yeah
no I'm not doing that oh yeah or there's
nowhere for you to shit before the show
so you got to go to shit were the
audience and everybody's like hey aren't
you the yeah
aren't you the girl that's gonna yeah
I'm just taking a shit man it's not fair
it's certainly not fair well we should
establish this we're jumping all over so
today we had an emergency yeah
are reliable and wonderful nanny who
comes on this day always at a certain
time and we do this show usually in a
certain window called in and had like
some family stuff right here's a family
emergency
that's the worst day to call in like
that this is our podcast and we have you
know tight schedule I'm in town I'm in
LA 48 hours I know so I was like a bad
week for this so actually and we also
had scheduled Martin Risa the water
sommelier so it was all like set up to
go and then everything got thrown away
so anyways I end up doing I ended up
doing the water session segment with
Martin right which is that tagged on to
the end of this episode it will be
Christine
pardon I was watching the baby gene
right and I put him down for his nap and
now we have maybe 45 minutes to get
there we just don't know we don't know
why would I mean the baby could freak
out so we have the monitor here just the
way it goes this is one of those
old-school podcast where we used this
when he was first a baby he'd been in
the next room and we do the show during
we would stop when we'd hear cries yes
so you do it guys this is the real your
mom tell hopefully he just crashes hard
here I hope he was up at like 5:00 a.m.
because the time change yeah and then
you know he's all fucked up because that
one hour dude really messes up babies
well yeah it does
fuck oh my god and then our front gate
malfunction and then like what else went
wrong right a fucking meeting yeah uh it
was just today's not a good day no but
it just got better with that diarrhea
clip the diarrhea clip really opened up
really did my happiness can i man and
you know what else I've been thinking
about my friend Sean I came I see there
the joy comes back into my life
my friend Sean I came to visit me my BFF
and and she listens to the show with her
husband Jimmy and she goes we worst we
were talking about
man that guy who takes 10 to 12 benadryl
she was I take one and I'm like anxious
and sweating you can take many benadryl
now she takes them regularly for her
allergies and she said that is way too
much you think that's a lot I mean what
about this guy that rock guys who love
the fucking fuck good I need to be
fucked a lot we got it we got it
what do you thinks the point of that he
really needs and he gave out he gave out
that address now don't you think a
Craigslist ad would suffice like he
needs to put a YouTube video out I think
he really wants I think he's trying to
step it up very indiscriminate think
about like a written ad it's like you
know and he's showing the goods here
he's saying like what look like yeah
it's bad show I got some nice pillows
you want a fire for what yeah
move in here your friends move in here
are you out of jail are you a homeless
bum you want to piss on me beat me up I
mean really somebody by the way can
definitely satisfy all of his knee I
know there's a person right now it was
like check check
I'm in Damon I'm homeless I'll piss on
you I'll beat the shit out of you I'll
fuck you and it's free rent yeah and my
friends can come gives it up to his
friends it's all winner really one of
the more substantial guys that's we've
ever played on this show that is quite a
singles ad you don't really get to see
those very often and again I think I
said it last week but I think everybody
understands the sentiment the impulses
of saying that but there's a big part of
you right now and you feel like when you
feel like I want to get fucked that goes
maybe I shouldn't make this video and
put it online though why do you imagine
the response was to that especially now
that we've broadcasted someone listening
some some derelict listener of this show
was like yeah well that one's great the
crazy thing is that you know somebody is
somebody wherever this is originally
posted has his full home address
like we edit it out for his sake great
great but his full home address is like
whatever 1 2 3 main street and he's like
that's where I live if you want to come
over here and piss on me for free rent
and bring you're out of jail friends to
bananas that's really it's wrong with
people you know I think it's crazy to
even show what neighborhood you live in
on Instagram yeah let alone you know
giving out your addy it's really wild oh
you want a piss and shit his cadence is
so it's that weird guy cadence - yeah
it's like that psychotic East Coast
didn't fuck me yeah like piss on me yeah
you tried it there's no break in the
words they run together I know that
that's a real sign of a psycho is when
there's no pauses yeah no blanking by
the way so you know they I've told
stories on this podcast about how as I
tour you know especially for the first
like nine months of this tour every time
I go to stay
I'm walking onto the stage in some
pretty big rooms as the applause dies
there's kind of like that moment right
so you grab the mic they're clapping and
you go thank you thanks a lot it's like
as you're about to start doing stand-up
right does that yes a lot of times it
was hey Hitler right now yeah now yeah
machines within people are screaming
machines within I like that
yeah well it's a hit song and we turned
it into it a smash hit yeah we are
responsible and our audience is
responsible yeah for creating such a
great song amazing new visions came in
amazing someone I've got this email that
I'm dying to read okay I got it came in
- that's deep bro which i think is
really funny but anyway you know
continue talking is yeah okay fine well
I have another machines within oh my god
great thought I would share it with you
looks like there's a video component to
this one as well here we go
[Music]
I love it right Elliot
I like it
[Music]
there you go it's good
it's really good usually the videos
great it's really great
[Music]
your thing on
it's really good I'm impressed yeah
Rasheed's with it that's great oh it's
so good
[Music]
I mean come on heat yeah like they made
it a soul fool yeah this is a soulful
thing
Eliot it says by Elliot yeah
[Music]
I'm impressed again I'm impressed I
really liked it
yeah did many other ones um well that's
all I see in here four machines within
submissions but we have some new she's
retarded song good so this is she's
retarded it's called it's
developmentally disabled by Daniel Keene
[Music]
okay okay she's retarded okay yeah she
sounds retarded there you go
that's really good Daniel T thank you
for that one this is retarded genes by
patty patty boo
[Music]
oh it's good no
kind of chill vibe that I like that I
told you how that when the started she's
retarded yeah it's kind of neat this is
called she's retarded light light jazz
by Eidos yeah okay I like it
oh yeah I like that
different I like the different David
Brubeck
[Music]
you don't normally hear like this no all
right I like that I guess who I met on
Saturday who gaping dad you're kidding
he came to my show in Austin he's like
your mom's house celebrity that's for
sure
and he's made incredible incredible
songs Wow and you know I told him I go I
want to thank you for all the songs
you've made you're definitely on our top
you know top tier yeah music songs that
he submitted have been incredible and he
goes aw thanks and then he goes uh I'm
working on if she's retarded what I
cannot wait to get off so I don't have
that yet
but you can't rush a genius no you know
but I believe in nature it's from an
indie who submitted a great I think he
submitted a machines within song also
submitted that she retarded and he yeah
he's an actual you know guitar player
and singer so remember oh yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
there you go
well I feel like that one really got the
message across right of like the
distinction between being retarded or
mentally to say yeah and it's such an
important distinction some people are
just retarded you know that's what that
guy was trying to say right her shit
she's retarded man like and he wasn't
trying to say she has downs she's
mentally to say he's like no she does
retarded chat retarded yeah like that do
you really think that's the hidden
meaning of she's retarded
100% of that she acts out all the time
oh yeah yeah look at Sally Sally's just
retarded now is retarded yeah it's so
silly ah yeah I think so man these song
I tell you every now and then we hit a
wave a real talent submissions on this
show and this is one of those times yeah
yeah and that when these songs come in
it's like it's really one of my favorite
things that happens really it really
really makes me happy I read this email
of course read the email
this is funny so it says hi Christina I
was listening to your mom's house
episodes we were discussing showering
with Tom I know if you guys remember
that episode but it started when we
lived at this other house a year ago and
Tom and I shower together on occasion
not so much anymore just for logistic
reasons yeah yeah but you came in and
you peed on me and it smelled like you
had dumped an entire carafe of coffee
into the shower cuz you don't hydrate a
lot and that's what started this whole
water champ look look what you're
drinking now is that doesn't look like
water to me it looks like coffee so it's
disgusting and then you blew snot
rockets and then they this not got stuck
in your beard and then like you just you
look a hobo it's like showering with a
guy who would dye my cheeks yeah
diarrhea yeah so she writes and I'm 21
years old and have never showered with
the guy the thought of being in a shower
with a guy as he's washing his bud hold
never appealed to me I have worked in
the nursing aide field for a couple of
years and I'm currently in nursing
school maybe all the years of bathing
pervy old men turned me off to the idea
the last time I stayed at my booze place
he mentioned that we shower together I
told him I didn't want to and he thought
that was weird what should I expect from
my first time showering with a guy how
do I make washing my armpits sexy our
blowjobs requirement or is it supposed
to be cute or both that's a really good
question and I think you know sweet
sounds like a sweet lady 21 young I
think first of all if if it's her bf
well first of all you know your bf you
know I mean like if you think you know
your bf and then you show at them and
figure out he's a hobo for years at that
point
and I'm saying is that I don't know what
stage of bf this is but obviously it's
it's a stage where they spend the night
each other's house she's been with him
for a while so it's not like it's a new
new thing I think more than likely if
he's asking you to shower for the first
time and it hasn't been done he doesn't
want to screw that up for the next first
time Yeah right so I think that stuff
later your first time you've nothing to
worry about like he's gonna be on
probably good behavior he's gonna soap
your back he's gonna do like yeah he'll
let you have the hot water and then that
just very quickly cuz when that's why we
don't shower together it's not I'll be
in the hot water enjoying myself and
then you will physically grab me and
pull me out of the world and then taking
I will rephrase that no that's what you
do I would rephrase that I would say
that I would like some some hot water
not scorching hot water so I have to
move you and turn the hot water down
which is actually saving hot water for
you because I take human showers but you
pull me out of the stream and then I
suffer shiver I need it for a moment but
look I think it'll probably be a nice
thing and you don't like yeah you soap
wherever you want he's gonna promise not
gonna wash his asshole in front of no
first time no no no help help put that
off yeah no I'll wash his dick and balls
he'll wash that and he'll probably like
try to get a couple grabs you know I
probably probably stick his finger in
your crack
he'll soap up your back so you know your
that's where you're wrong because not
all men are as derelict
as you are or you
that were you need to spread my butt
cheeks with your fingers jerk-off
implants what about that weird right not
all guys do that kind of stuff you think
it's playful but I'll tell you that but
you're definitely you know rare I'd
never had a boyfriend that would do all
that mean stuff to me mean was mean
spreading my butt cheeks remember I used
to take her you go like that why are you
spreading him peeing on me I didn't have
a boyfriend that did that until you you
said that the spreading was menacing
menacing yeah I didn't like it
I didn't like it I just tolerate it
Excel of you I didn't it's another red
flag I should have paid attention to
probably there's a few right oh so many
well your love of sociopaths and
murdering and stuff like that that was a
big red flag no you didn't use soap in
your shower stuff like that yeah yeah
yeah you're washing you're washing your
crotch with shampoo that's what people
do no not all people everything I did to
you is normal yeah sure it is now this
gave me a laugh I thought you might like
this this lady she's retarded is
retarded going through her car wash
creature there's some over here
yeah having a good time right yeah
enjoying the carwash
[Laughter]
they just fucked up the interior of
their car yeah she had moose soup vibes
definitely soon yeah so basically for
those who aren't watching on YouTube the
Sun roof leaked and this woman is in a
drive-thru car wash and all the water
just got in her yeah
fucked up her car so the it looks like
the will probably happen is the the
interior slides closed and the I bet you
the top window is that that elevated
positions you know how they have they
have that feature though where you can
be like oh it's not open back it's like
lift it up sure you have like a breeze
of air oh my god and I think she she
didn't realize that that's terrible yeah
that's pretty bad that your car is over
oh maybe so I'll be just as pissed as
she is just so terrible
that's really really your car's totally
ruined yeah and they've got leather
interior it was poor it wasn't trickling
especially on the passenger side look
how much water is flowing it's trickling
in there but look to the right here
there
that is a you're right I think it's
cracked up yeah I think it's propped up
yeah
and whose fault would that be I think
would be the driver's fault yeah that's
true
it's her car damn dude she's super
pissed car washes are fun when you're
sitting in the car
yeah it still is a thrill of course yeah
I don't like it when they take my car I
like to sit in it yeah it's very similar
could be her yeah dirty bitch right it
has kind of that vibe yeah yeah so maybe
her cousin here oh my god right here the
little mix-up there oh wow yeah that was
very close
that's awesome gene that's pretty good
[Laughter]
so this is interesting armless wiping
solved aah I was listening an episode
420 I had an epiphany I worked at a
movie theater for years once while I was
working a co-worker walked into the
handicapped washroom and found shit
covered toilet paper wrapped around the
grab bar next to the toilet I have spent
years pondering how this happened it is
now obvious to me that an armless person
had an emergency Brown wrapped the
toilet paper around the bar with their
highly skilled feet and then rubbed up
on it obviously after they were done
they had no way of getting it off
without getting their feet covered in
shit mystery solved
hope this was of some help machines
within FA is what they agreed the whole
thing now wow that's an interesting
theory I don't see why not
yeah it's possible it's definitely
possible
sir in gender specific high Hitler's
when trying to be sensitive to people's
pronouns what do those who speak big
words with gender types in their speech
do Spanish French Italian have non Zim's
er types in their words built in and
will never be able to respect the
pronoun because so many words being
masculine and feminine that is fucking
brilliant and that is so true
are these languages doomed to be sis
scum speech for all eternity and should
we be eliminating them to make sure
everyone is safe please respond with
your wrists run in the industry Wow Alan
that is good that's a really good point
because the respectful languages the
Germans they have neuter form right
right but they're right here the there
are some languages that don't have a
neutral a new gender neuter and he's and
such a good question as a someone who
speaks you know decent Spanish I can
tell you that you're always constantly
trying to remember you know right
somebody like I said I you know my
Spanish has definitely gone downhill
because I don't use it as much as I used
to but that is a thing where it's like
is it is it masculine or feminine is the
word Mesa or El Mesa right is it LA let
me say yeah right because it ends an
island now there so you're attributing a
feminine you know oh my gosh title to
the word right of course then how are
the non-binary people going to tolerate
this in these lands because you have to
say something to somebody in countries
they uh so what would they say I have no
idea actually that's that's why I'm
fascinated by this how do how does this
this whole movement of gender pronouns
affect people that don't speak English
because we have been just been tied into
the english-speaking world right and
we've seen the
documentary that vice documentary that
was it Sweden yeah I think it was
they have hen which is the neutral right
he was like or it they were like do you
want to be like a woman or
gender-neutral day and then the kid was
like I just wanna go by my name how
about mark yeah I know it's so funny
because Ellis is about the age of the
kid that they're asking on a daily basis
what they feel like and I'm like looking
at my kid like he doesn't even
understand the question yeah there's
there's no debate in his mind like about
what gender yeah it's just not on the
table yet yeah it's a look at it Skyy
think you're confusing him
I'm sorry them a little bit they get
confused but in I'm interested in the
Latin speaking if anyone out there has
any insight into whether Spanish French
Italian speakers how they approach
somebody who's like I'm not either
gender yeah how do words then get used I
guess these words are very much they
have a a gender like tie-in to them in
those languages
yes it's very there's a few ways I think
you can say something gender-neutral
that's true that's absolutely true well
in German you have deidara and das those
are three different feminine masculine
and neuter and you have to fucking
memorize every word with deidara das
that's terrible yeah so hard interesting
where do non binaries go to prison well
that's cool well in California didn't we
just have the thing that transgender
people which is what this person asked
they said I heard that California
allowed to put a third gender on your
license separate from male or female so
I was thinking if you're one of those
people and you have to go to prison do
you go to male prison or a female prison
thanks fish abuser well I mean if
they're non they're non-binary I'm you
know I would assume they put them with
the women I think we need to build new
prisons entirely right it makes sense
makes sense yeah for that community no I
think they do send them to the women's I
think it's to get the guys you know what
it is it's so that the guys don't get
this shit beaten out of them
well let's say I'm saying let's say I go
hey I'm non-binary and and then the
state recognized it they go Tom Segura
non-binary right it's on his driver then
their driver's license right and I
commit a crime right I get sent to
prison and I go I'm not male I can't go
to a men's prison no they already
already acknowledged that I'm not I'm
not a man and you're not a female either
No
so now dude we'll have to figure about
to find out oh yeah well because this is
such your wheelhouse yeah I thought I
would play this special treat is it
diarrhea and non-binary it's very
educational okay and you're a reader
you're the learner yeah but I think it's
your type of education okay okay hey
everybody its Stephen saiva here and I'm
here to talk to you about something
that's near and dear to my heart my boy
and I call it sacred releasing okay here
we go
so what's sacred releasing is is it's a
way of transforming using the toilet
going to the bathroom from something
that's mundane into something that's
really magical transforming it into a
sacred ritual isn't it always I feel
like it's always pretty awesome I think
he points out one of your big flaws how
present are you when you're going to the
bathroom and the reason why we're asking
that is because I know we have this
tendency in our society you know in this
day and age to be toilet textures you
know we go to the bathroom with a phone
and then we can be sitting on the tanks
for the reenact yeah yeah that's why you
tweeted releasing transforms and honors
this letting go process is releasing
process that is using the toilet this
might be my second favorite new clip
already great sacred releasing I love
that you definite I was judging though
right yeah why I didn't even know this
was an option for me it's funny that you
love shitting and I love jizzing yeah
more shitting clips cuz I feel like
we've been a little jizz heavy okay
this is my wheelhouse now I thought
that's why you took a shit was to catch
up on your emails and your texts and
your
[Music]
sacred releasing so he's just arguing
that you should be more present more
mindful more thoughtful and more
appreciative of your body processing
that shit yeah why are you sitting there
doing other things you should be
thinking about this moment but I feel
like you process your dumb so you like
them yeah you like candles and you pray
I don't pray but I'm where I'm in there
I like a full report you tried so much
in our spiritual communities oh boy
that people do this really beautiful
nice gratitude filled prayer like ritual
free eating a meal and then when it
comes Hut the other side right right
great logic right what why isn't that
prayer happening now that it's been
digested it's not good enough for you
anymore it's an interesting topic should
we be like I gotta take a shit and then
be like dear God thank you thank you for
thank you yeah thank you for this shit
thank you for helping me get through my
system and then kind of really losing
yourself in it like as it kind of you
know it pushes out yeah especially those
those growlers you know those yeah those
really fierce ones I don't know I mean I
think it's kind of interesting I feel
like there should be a whole sect of
religious people that are devoted to
this you know how there are like monks
that starve themselves I bet you there's
a whole sect of people who just worship
their duties no there's people there's
some people that have other people
worship their duties for people like her
her buddy and they get in there do we
have to be present all the time that's
the question I would I would ask him is
like dude listen taking a dump it's
probably one of the most enjoyable
mindless things I get to do yeah every
day that's why it's awesome it's you
alone or sometimes with toddler on your
lap or it's hardly running around but
mostly alone yeah where you check out
and you just didn't do it enjoy a body
function yeah why do I have to fucking
can we just be mindless yeah
what am I supposed to know I can just
believe it in in a different room and
just set it aside and don't even go to
the bathroom with your phone what I'm
encouraging and supporting you to do is
to leave the phone out of the backers
completely and what I encourage you to
do is just drop in with yourself and let
this be a moment where you honor the
sacred bringing in and letting go
process that is this sacred rhythm that
we have in life and in the universe kind
of a beautiful statement though yeah I
like his earrings those are unique
they're they're alternative like they
look spicy the spiky and hurtful like
they look like they hurt yeah I'm
getting my ears pierced both of them
yeah it's a really good idea you don't
like it I didn't say I didn't like it
it was a really good idea but I sensed
like some type of you know what what
kind of earrings are you gonna get I'm
gonna start with gold studs yeah
definitely and and then I'm going to
I'll do hoops and then I'm gonna do
diamonds I'm just gonna I like diamonds
on you you look good you think so
sparkling you want me to get a tattoo
I've been talking about it for a long
time okay I want to get those knuckle
tats we've been talking about oh yeah
just fuck you money on there yeah I
think you should have fucking money
before you get it true that's a problem
I'll be funny you're doing your next
special and it's like a fuck you holding
the mic like it'd be great if Seinfeld
had those for this late-night special
and I said fuck you money on his hands
I'd be like that's awesome yeah but I
think you I don't want to get that tat
you probably wait yeah yeah but I do
like those knuckle tats that's gonna
happen in this lifetime and I feel like
you want a tat you've been talking about
it it's my like midlife crisis thing
yeah I've been reverting him to my goth
stuff a lot but I do I kind of want that
dude is there any place you're
considering yeah the inner arm here in
ER for yes the forum the problem is is
that I feel like in ten years when I'm a
fifty year old woman yeah I'll feel like
a dick bag I don't think so I feel like
a fucking out I really don't think so
you don't think it'll be undignified
when I'm like 85 all you have to have it
tastefully done you got it you're gonna
have to have it
by a good artist and there's definitely
a dignified way of doing it yeah one of
it's a sacred poop like my favorite poop
what do you mean dirt you don't have a
favorite bowel movement are you gonna
you're saying you're gonna date it
commemorate it so you'll be like 18 yeah
people be like oh has someone died but
no shit all right you already have the
message in mind yeah yeah I want Mike my
kids name or something yeah
my son mm-hmm my son my your son right
definitely portraits of our dogs too
don't you have his face it always looks
good when somebody has their child's
face tattooed on them never looks bad no
always looks good no forever forever my
child he'll be like Oh changes and it
looks like I think he wasn't some type
of chemical warfare actor
yeah I do like a trident or an octopus
or something like that an octopus make
it cool one maybe shelve your idea for a
while 20-30 years and revisit it I know
that's why I get the urge and I'm like I
should hold on I like your idea I think
it'd look cool why had the bad idea in
the 90s of getting a fucking tramp stamp
of a dragon yeah look how that was yeah
your aim here thing yeah I hate it now
the thing is though do I go through the
pain of removing it or do I just like
fuck it just I don't know depends on how
much it bothers it's embarrassing remove
it
yeah but I think the one you have in
mind is actually cool I really do my
kids name I think in Old English though
yeah on my chest chest I would do paws I
love the eve has those yeah those are
fucking super weird right why the pot
why did why the cat paws on her chest I
was wondering it's it's um shows you fun
times yeah he plays with titties that's
the whole idea
oh it's like waiting cat steps on your
chest and she's like commemorating where
the cat steps are yeah exactly
you know when bitsy steps like it's just
getting you to look at titties it's just
like fun there's don't you look though
don't you slut shame me don't you look
at my titties cuz I have tattoos on them
there's a lot of uh that's my favorite
I've seen a lot of tattoos
if you if you kind of go down rabbit
holes of horrific alee terrifying ones
near generals it's pretty crazy you know
talking about yes like people have like
the devil tattooed above their box so it
looks like the devil such a crazy choice
it's such a choice crazy one like one
guy I had poison the word poison
tattooed on his dong and then arrow
pointing towards the tip that's pretty
much that's crazy talk
yeah goddamn mm-hmm or there's a really
others if you go I mean they're all over
but like crazy asshole ones yeah where
it's som something demonic
and then the your asshole is is it's
drawn on there so that your asshole is
the mouth yeah so it's like I think a
crazy Dean and then your mouth I mean
like yeah and then people have put like
funny things you know around their
assholes which I guess I appreciate it
as a comedian sure and just as a human
being but you're also getting your
asshole tattooed that's the thing I
think about is that I mean at her listen
I've only had the tramp stamp and that
wasn't comfortable yeah but I can't
imagine the asshole being an easy place
to tattoo it's gotta be it's gotta be
nuts it might be this most sensitive
besides your genitals yeah I mean or
your eyelids I don't even know how they
give eyelid tattoos I've seen those on
television not ivory often in real life
yeah just on those crime shows
there's some inmates with seen eyelids
I've seen you know whole face is just
nuts
why is bold in her lip I've seen that
I've seen that you know it so bad that
doesn't last forever you know that yeah
I've seen a bottom of a foot tattooed
which I'm like that just has to you know
that's just for you for your amusement
sure but also that I feel like that
would be painful and not good super
painful but I feel like yeah face is
pretty great and I like the neck
actually I do like a chest piece yeah I
like it on girls when I see it looks
really tough I like how you like the
toughness of it yeah yeah I wrote you
like throat Thank You ash
there was a drug dealer that I went to
college with and he had a nice story a
lot of throat and he had like he was
like a white guy with dreads but he wore
he rode a motorcycle like he was he was
tough as fuck actually hitting a knuckle
tattoo the neck yeah I mean but some
dudes it's like they're born that way
like they look good this guy's hot
everyone wears both his dreads
well that's see that's where you lost me
at know what's the banging no white guy
yes
everybody did duty white guy with dreads
I'm telling you never again it's very
rare but this boy was so goddamn he you
know how like a dude figures out a look
yeah in your life houses look dude
knuckle tattoo throat dreads blunt like
bleached white and then do you think the
dress look good yes I'm saying and I
don't say this I'll never say this again
maybe Rob Zombie can pull it off and
this guy so did you guys make love I
wish no but my roommate at one point did
the one who I would predict would like
if knowing the for the roommates know
you no one even knows no no she
you wouldn't even know her and just give
you like stories like yes I felt she
fell in love with him oh really
the campus drug dealer and then he was
like nah cuz he had this really cute
girlfriend that he was with and he kind
of cheated on the girl well yeah he's
the throat tattoo yeah white guy with
dreads dude he even had like a hot ass
friend you know and like hot dudes they
roll like their best friend's hot but
they were like 25 a dime you know saying
like I was a freshman in college and
these dudes were like 25 and still in
college and dealing drugs I know that
Lane well because I'm one of those guys
I've been the hot guy and like I walk in
it's like me Josh Potter you know right
oh my god hey yeah we're super hot
Sickler hot guys was how we roll because
we know the posters we got to knock that
shit down you helped yeah okay I can't
fuck all this tonight I can't fuck all
this site yeah well what that I can't
even magic that's like as a young man to
be that guy that all the girls wanna
bang yeah it's probably overwhelming I'm
assuming I'm sure yet hepatitis or
something
he was probably nasty as hell you
unclean definitely he did he probably
lived his best life I mean think about
he's got a motorcycle oh did you got
throat tattoo money definitely bad
decision I don't care about the hit
where you think it's a bad decision so
he made a bad decision but he embraced
it yeah he's got he's selling drugs yeah
all the chicks like in box yeah
girlfriend was hot girlfriends hot he's
fucking yeah he lived his best life he
did it'd be awesome if you could get an
update on him right now uh whoever went
to school with me and you're listening
you know who I'm talking about if you
can text me then get that I can't
actually I know who knows and get get a
look get a gander of what's going on now
if he's alive because I would say he was
on the fast track to die you see right
because he did a lot of the bad drugs I
do not have an update on the hot friend
yeah Sarah sent it to me he's not hot
anymore yes he is comfortable 20 years
yeah he's pudgy and like he's like
everybody now middle-aged there's a
window for that kind of shit dude you
still you got to get your tat you're
gonna regret I feel like that's what
this whole thing was about back you got
to get your time man
they saying I should have slept with the
campus drug dealer it's a hundred
percent if you would had that story
right now I would have loved it I didn't
do anything like dude he he did things
to me like I've never heard of and like
it hurt but like and I cried a lot bit
was like it's still good yeah you know
sure
then the his hot friend came in and I
was I was airtight well stop yourself
you know what so I was talking about I
feel like this whole thing about you
know we're we lied the words we should
do a slut walk everyone's allowed to be
a whore I feel like we've always been
allowed to be a whore like I don't know
of course what these uptight girls are
like in the 90s all my friends were
sluts it's all the whores it's just
doing it it's people who have their they
have insecurities about being the whore
in other words they're judging that girl
that sleeps around and they feel weird
about it yeah they want to be as
comfortable as she is with it don't work
everyone loves whores we're all my
friends were hoes and all every nobody
talk shit to them no everyone loves it
especially in San Francisco when I went
to college it was like cool it was cool
no one fucking slut shame people felt
like it was like hanging outside of a
bakery and like they're like we're gonna
we're gonna run out of we have too many
cupcakes left over
you like cupcakes yeah no but we all
talk and I went to an all-girls Catholic
High School
we were so sex-positive like I remember
in 10th grade our friend gave her first
blowjob she came in the next day and
announced it and we all fucking
high-fived her nobody was like oh you're
a whore like yeah we loved that stuff I
think let's get through this because we
gotta get LJ here fuck he's up alright
let's go how we do it there's a few
steps to this process step number one is
it involves going to the bathroom we
engage an intention we bring in a
visualization we do a form of toning can
I just take a shit actually like making
a sound no oh a quick hit above the
sound is to flush things down our energy
channel and out our route it's helpful
if we make hello Sam and if we're
bringing things up through the upper
chakras and out our crown we want to
make a higher tone and so we can use
this toning tool to help us move excess
energy in our body that might not be
serving I feel like I make that sound
already when I should do this he lives
alone when we go to the bathroom a root
area is not only opening up physically
to let things go but it's also opening
up energetically to let things right and
so there's once this energetic center is
open yeah and we're releasing this with
our intention I'm gonna let go of some
anxiety that I'm feeling in my belly and
like help it encourage it down he's
sweet he goes but he goes through all
this to take a shit his life is too
complicated
he definitely lives by himself important
cuz we're opening up physically yeah and
energetic rest it's important to that
gun we're done and complete our sacred
releasing ritual that we close the
energy and your asshole energy loves to
leak out we've heard about this
phenomena yeah yeah it does the leaky
energy problem yeah especially with
women you got to close that no or close
your badge you can easily leak out
adding the goat a Honda
[Music]
but you're saying that King a surfers
been practicing this for years
breathing appreciating what he ate
he's an intentional fighter and a
shitter yeah yep I mean he's been doing
he's been mindful doing for a long time
before this guy he's really been doing
it um oh oh my god that was great
I was fantastic no more dump clips
really I really like I feel like this
really lifted my spirit this is what I
needed today thank you so much for
really bringing the clips that I would
respond to it
I'm glad Thank You blue van and yeah I
really feel like very exciting so
normally we would have had Martin Risa
together but we don't because of our
circumstances so jealous tonight that's
what you're gonna see now if you keep
watching this podcast or keep listening
we're gonna attack on a segment where
Martin brought presents which I don't
want to give away yet and he also
brought three new waters to try which I
have to get you to try them sound like a
sight and then that's it it should be
really fun so thank you too Martin Risa
for coming in go to the patina
restaurant downtown LA thanks for
listening please go to your mom's house
podcast calm you know the deal you know
the tickets are on sale for the tour you
know the merch thank you guys as always
for listening to the podcast and we'll
see you next week Jean nice jeans all
right this is a nice treat for us in
this case particularly me because
well sure we discussed it during the
episode but we have no we had a nanny
call in sick today
which happens that's life so I the more
important true water champ of the family
I'm going to enjoy some nice new waters
we're being revisited by Martin Risa the
water sommelier the international number
one water sommelier who also you can you
can visit if you'd like to you can go
and they can make a reservation and more
at the patina right at patina restaurant
in downtown Los Angeles and the oldest
icons at home yeah I'm always there for
you and actually we had some guests who
saw me here on the show last time coming
over now to patina and there was a lot
of fun really do some water tasting with
them and they really enjoyed it and a
lot of fun it's a fun experience I feel
like that was the it was a funny episode
like when you participant you came over
the first time all these people were
like what the fuck are you doing having
this guy on I think this is totally
normal
even I'm getting the same response in
the restaurant yeah I'm it's like when
you're giving them water manual turn the
mama water someone yeah I think like
you're right yeah right what's wrong
with you but then they were all
fascinated like and I've been on this
thing to where you know I travel a lot
I'm meeting people all the time
sometimes water comes up it always comes
up when somebody grabs a water like
let's say I'm going from the hotel or
the airport to the hotel and then the
you know the showrunner the person that
runs the the theater runner who's like
will run help you run errands the day
you're in town he will stop in and then
I'll see them pick up like a bottle of
smart water I'll be like nah man you
can't do that that's garbage dude throw
that shit out and then we start having
talks about minerals
I don't becomes this fascinating thing
where it's almost like there's so many
things in life that are convenient to
not know that you just go like I don't
have time to care about everything now
but then there's certain things where
you go well it's important enough for me
to to give a shit about so especially I
think when you're putting something into
your body
I think you should really come out of
what you're putting into about of course
it's very very important water is is
pretty essential yeah you see that an
artist made this oh that is cool I mean
look at that that is awesome that is
they love this says the water champion
sculpted that whole thing incredible
that is really awesome yeah I love this
yeah yeah there's an additional so
gaming sauna yeah you got a lot of
traction I mean you know from the
podcast a lot of people were into that
did you get some fun interesting
messages and emails from people the
first thing and I was like completely
shocked obviously when the first guy
said hi Hitler and I was like what the
hell what did I do
and then I realized because I watch more
episodes yeah and then I realized oh no
I'm getting it you're like there's it's
not just me it's not just me I'm not
just because I'm can perfectly say hi
hello obviously yeah I'm an accent but
now I getting it and and this was
obviously a little shocking in the
beginning for getting it now I'm getting
it now I'm totally fine with this
yeah yeah she she's pretty wild she's
got serious problems yeah yeah nobody
was really fun to be on this show and I
never thought I getting so much response
out of that yeah I don't know I've I
gained hundreds of followers suddenly
people were all over me they sent me
text messages I'm still getting
Instagram posts all the time now and and
having you with me with their water
they're drinking and asked me hey what
do you think about this what about your
thing about that water and I'm trying
obviously my best always total response
to everybody that's great and in saying
like hey cool how thank you so much for
thinking about me and and I love this
this is so cool and because the whole
idea I think we want to engage with
people yeah I'm gonna talk about what
and I want to give water value that's
the whole point why I was on the first
place here as well and what it should be
fun and what it should be enjoyable and
and it's it's great to be back
well good I'm so happy to have you back
and I really feel like - it's like it's
one of those things where
with water it is something you engage
with every day so like even all the
jokes aside from our podcast I mean
you're gonna have water every day I mean
we are and I feel like you coming on
just open my eyes to the possibilities
and to the information like the
education of it so it's been fascinating
for me man like I really do think about
it now when I'm in these like I said all
over the country different cities have
different options where was I was just
in Texas and when I went to or was I was
either in I think it was when I was in
San Antonio San Antonio yeah it was I
went to this pretty nice restaurant
we're having a pre-show meal and the
guys like you know they're trying to
sell us their cocktails I was like we're
gonna do show so I just went sparkling
water and he goes do you want a
Pellegrino or Baba and something I
hadn't heard and like yeah I go what's
that and he goes what's that he goes oh
that's a Mexican sparkling water topo
Chico it's a staple of maybe San Antonio
and I go so trouble Chico okay very very
great cool Sparky well I go hook that
shit up man let's have some Mexican
Spartacus so it was like a fun you know
normally I don't even know if you if you
hadn't been here and kind of talked
about trying stuff I may have just been
like I don't know what that is I'll take
Pellegrino but I now I try to experiment
and try to have a little more then
you've just been through so buctober I
know man oh and yeah but I think even
for people who say like okay I want to
be a whole month without alcohol yeah
they are other options for you sure and
it's not just about other option means
like sodas or juices or something like
that ya know water has options as well
and there are some really really cool
stuff on it yeah yeah and that is the
fun thing oh my god I drink so much
water on Thursday night I went to this
place that had a speakeasy attached to
it and they have their like a bourbon
bar bourbon whiskey's and everything and
they're having me try Japanese whiskey's
and all this shit I mean after about an
hour and a half yeah - yeah very cool
stuff yeah I have this is why the
restaurant
after an hour and a half of that I was
like hey man I need to start drinking
some water and I think I had like 11
glasses of water before I left the real
audition yeah and I was also becoming
the drunk champ so I was like I actually
felt somewhat okay the next morning I
think because I just pounded why yeah
it's important yeah the thing is what a
lot of people always don't think like
they thinking or alcohol makes you're
dehydrated that's actually not really
true right our goal is to make sure more
going to the restroom yeah that's the
reason that's the whole point why you're
dehydrating because you keep going
you'll keep going keep going keep going
the whole time and you're forgetting
maybe to drink water so when you
replenish yourself all the time with
some good mineral water
there will be no hangover and eckstein
really it will be fine you'll be fine
I'm I'm very very tempted to just grab
stuff I'm so excited
you brought three to try today I yeah I
brought three different waters but
before that I have a little present for
you oh okay and just made the file you
sent me or no so the first present and
this is actually for you and because you
did the whole Lambeau geni prank yeah
yeah and I love this yeah and before
that you told me you were the head champ
now as well that's right that's right
and I know your addiction to cars yeah
and I have to admit I love cars to Mars
are fun man I ordered something from
Germany for you what and I think this
would be a perfect little present so I
get you the perfect martini racing
Porsche I love that for you yeah you're
a gentleman thank you sir so I think
there will be a nice thing especially
when the Sun is blowing yeah and this
will be a great hat for you when you're
driving your your nice car thank you sir
maybe you need to change through the
pack or something else yeah dude that's
very nice of you thank you for that I
thought like I I saw that and I feel
like this is the perfect gift for Tom
yes here we go dude it looks perfect
yeah
love this love it and then I brought
something for you both and I have a
little video as well but I want to
showcase first what I brought because
obviously I'm working a restaurant yeah
yeah and you guys talked
all the time about eating stuff as well
on the show mm-hmm
I brought soup what what you brought
real mu soup real mu soup created
yesterday by my Michelin star chef
andreas roller and I have a video here
where you can see never we created this
yesterday holy cow there's real no soup
for the main mummies oh my god this is
unbelievable
oh my god hold on this is unn you did
not even tell me you were doing this by
the way because otherwise I would have
had this no no that's the reason yes
here we go
I just sent and this is the reason I
just sent you the link via drop yeah cuz
I didn't know that you were sneaking on
me and like hell what are you sending me
like let's check it out yeah yeah then I
wouldn't have that surprise so it was
for me important to get some mu soup in
the beginning and obviously some people
will see like what the hell is this here
why is Martinez like this crazy bunch
here but this is like how we're
presenting or preserving actually stuff
at the restaurant so we're cooking
everything and then it goes into a
vacuum yeah and then it will be staying
perfectly for I cannot believe you're a
genius so this is actually a real good
mu soup from the mousse is coming from
Vermont actually freshly flown this is
that this is mousse soup who is this
real Musa okay I think we're going to
lose our minds so should I open it up
definitely okay it's a little video so
there's no really sound so you can you
can move the sound but address a little
video about where we actually are so
it's smooth super Tina stylus it's funny
because I was about to say to you that
like we should tell the audience what
Hal of a restaurant correctly so it's a
Michelin star restaurant it's one of the
flagships what we operating it's the
number one restaurant in Los Angeles and
this is andreas runner i execute a chef
and this is like this is what we're
plating like for example turbo like a
little salmon crostini
kuma a little devil eggs little sweets
so this is the actually move what we
received from my monde yesterday and
he's like carving it right now and these
are my filets you can see it's very very
dark meat it's beautiful very red meat
this is a beautiful little garlic
obviously for the beautiful breath
I know you love I love you love you love
garlic breath I love garlic breath if
I'm gonna give a kiss to Christina they
are all the different ingredients
obviously as well from this is I'll be
putting it into into a little so this
guy's a stud shaft oh yeah he's a master
degree on chef as well from German he
comes from a three-star Michelin as
strong in in Germany the hotel tauba
tauba and he really knows his shit yes
no he's putting some fire on it as well
to get some roast aromas to the moose
yeah and he had a lot of fun as well to
it so obviously he wouldn't and this is
not a thumb right there you did the
right thing yeah they are like different
herbs in it and we don't want that the
herbs are touching actually the food we
just want the aromas of the herbs really
putting it into this more little smarter
back and then we're putting it back out
later on and then it's getting reductive
a little bit of I'm blown away here we
go and this is like how the finished
product looks like I'm blown away
there we go let's see what the chef yeah
so I haven't tasted it yet he just
tasted it but I'm very excited for you
and you should try it out I get my back
as well at home so I think this will be
a lot of fun on dude it is on that's so
nice of you thank you sure thing sure
thing because everybody was talking
about mousse soup and I was like okay mo
super moves have I never heard about
this yeah and then I was finding out a
little bit and then I talked to undress
my chef and he's like there let's cook
someone so let's make it and we did this
yesterday and we had a lot of fun
actually with that that is so he enjoyed
it as well that's yeah that says as cool
a thing as I've heard somebody doing
thank you yeah that's we're gonna we're
gonna do it she should come down as well
she should yeah yeah she I wonder what
she would think of a Michelin stars
version of a most elusive love to know
this as well because I saw pictures and
they already look like poof of apes or
something like this is like Apes it's
like there's some disgusting moves so
pictures online I have to say that it's
like really some pictures were like
literally like okay when you were really
really sick and you're going to the
you're going to the restroom and you
already know there are some problems
with your stomach and you
looking afterwards what happened to your
in in the in the toilet and this is like
sometimes what mousse it looks like oh
my god are these photos to be looked at
as well or is it because like I was here
in March or April 8th yeah this year and
there's so many things happened I was in
China there are a big water tasting
there over a hundred different waters
and I will be coming up on Netflix for
the Bill Nye show oh that's great so
yeah the science the science guy I had a
lot of fun with this guy and he invited
me to do a water tasting and he gave me
three different waters the first water
was an attempt the second water was
double distilled water what I refused to
drink mm-hmm because I said like what
the fuck why should I drink double
distilled water there's no benefits for
me so forget it
yeah I'm not drinking this and the third
water what we're seeing right now they
are exploitation life support water yeah
this is actually out of space water from
the international space ship this is
their recycled water what they are
drinking
so it's astronaut water this is what
they're drinking this is what they're
drinking on the spaceship also in space
in space they have to recycle their
water yes so this was the most unique
water I ever tasted in my life so it's
water recovery and management from the
NASA Marshall Space Flight Center and
when you go on the next page or the next
photo you will see what that actually is
so it's recycled water made from waste
products extracted by the employees of
summer 2015 actually it's out of this
world yeah it was out of this world
because this is nothing out than sweat
shower water distilled urine
condensation and then they're adding
some similar to make it more purified
and clean what waste products excreted
by the employees so I was drinking that
I even revisit that water so I drink it
twice and they all looked at me there
was one comedian right next to me he's
like what the fuck like you're you
you're refusing to drink double
distilled water but you're drinking that
shit yeah and I was like yeah I want to
taste that
it has extremely heavy smell first so
when you're smelling that glass it's
smelled like when you walk into a
dentist office yeah if this chemical
very like weird smell yeah it was very
sweet and taste
code SILVER add sweetness to your water
yeah it was not yummy let's face this a
slogan water was it what's wrong the
time is it's not really but it's you can
you can taste like this whole chemical
aspect to it mm-hmm
it's like Ali tap times 5 in this
chlorine and silver and camera you can
really smell and drink chemicals it's
not really enjoyable
is there a rated I mean were they able
to find out the mineral content no water
no and it's highly distilled a sponsor
or I say the middle content has to be
extremely low extremely low yes
otherwise if it wasn't stripped it would
be like getting people sick so the fun
part about this water is that honestly
the ISS the international space it has
two divisions
it's a Russian division and an American
division the Russians recycling the
water as well but they don't use their
own urine they're like Nana that's too
nasty force so the Americans even
collecting the rain of the Russians and
user yes and using that as well
interesting
interesting story about that that's
really wax so you will see me on Netflix
episode 4 on the second season that's
coming up hopefully an end of November
unbelievable
I love this but it was a lot of fun next
one can I go the next page yes shooting
err yeah it's like a picture of Bill now
and then yeah with me and this is like
the three waters up there and the
producer came up to me and because they
want to do a blind taste first with me
so they put all the three waters and I
was just smelling them I could tell them
right away which waters what really yeah
they're like what are you the smell
champ no oh yeah yeah you know it's like
you can smell the difference and the tap
was just the pool from the backyard
yeah then this double distilled water
had no smell at all and then this urine
astronaut water was just like disgust
house no yeah or just disgusting and
this is like on the show that was like
for my wife took the pictures from the
audience and that's very so it will be a
fun little really fun sequence oh that's
great man it'll be a good one okay so
the next picture and this is a water
what I brought it's called civil body
from Norway and this picked the the
bottle already is kind of stunning
because I will open this bottle is it
this one Oh
this is like what you buy high-end
liquor comes in a case like that it has
the price of a high-end liquor it does
so it runs one hundred and fifty dollars
in the restaurant he had it yes 50 bucks
that cost you when you want to buy it
retail and one hundred and fifty were
charging at the restaurant but we are
selling it
people are really addicted to it really
really interesting it so is this a flat
water yes I brought Stillwater's today I
thought like today is still November
month we drink a still water still water
this is from Norway from Norway this
comes from from the under arches so it's
a polar iceberg water so the milk
content obviously is extremely low 21
TDS mm-hmm very very long because this
water has never been touched on the
ground it's like rain water drips down
it goes right away on the ice glacier
and freezes up this waters around 15,000
years old what's in the bottle right
here and I see the picture right here so
they're harvesting these icebergs and
all some people would say like are you
not smart and so you we all know like
global warming and everything yeah oh
you're like taking the ice box even my
waist yeah no these are ice packs were
breaking down like totally normal
they're starting to dilute then into the
North Sea and when they are deluded you
cannot use that water anymore coat then
it's like heavily salted yeah so they're
picking up this huge icebergs and you
can see like they're tonnes they have a
super-heavy they have our own vessel
they're picking up these icebergs and
then melting them down into this bottle
so it's something very cost intensive
and they're fast intensive and also it's
not gonna be that they're not gonna make
million now and I think they did 10,000
bottles faster so that's why the price
point is gonna be elevated it's
something very very unique that's a
fascinating so it's a very fun
interesting water to start your soap and
remember maybe oh my goodness and it's
gonna be as you mentioned a pretty low
yeah yeah but but it's still a distinct
flavor or know it's interesting putts so
I had three bottles already in tasting
and all three bottles tasted slightly
different and that makes sense because
it's a mother it's a product of nature
again and all these icebergs they're
floating into the sea so obviously all
these icebergs have a slightly different
flavor to it and the name again is small
body
about is the region and Norway and they
calling that water swaths of our body so
let's see what this version tastes like
mm-hmm to me it's very smooth
yeah yeah very very smooth I think so
too it's very smooth but it has when you
drink it and it's it's right away gone
yes like it's almost dries out your
palate I think yeah it doesn't really
have this refreshing aspect to it that's
interesting and that is because it's
lacking minerals because it's lacking
yes because there's not enough minerals
and there so the your body on your mouth
saying like hey what's gonna get some
more can I get some more because there's
like barely anything in there so I want
more water to get more minerals
interesting that's a good water I like
it it's extremely because it's so smooth
it's very nice for wines so when you
have like a 10 enriched red wine or
something like that yeah or maybe a
risky what you just told me that will
very very cool work with us because this
this heaviness of alcohol will be smooth
the way of this very smooth water so
it's a it's a very good water and I
don't want to drink everything because I
think your wife Christina need to drink
something as well and she will kill both
of us I think when we probably when we
killing the bottles here just for us and
we don't we don't share that some be
mean but I have to say that is a very
pleasurable tasting in other words yeah
it's enjoyable I think so too it's not
it's something that you go like oh okay
I mean the satisfying sip of water oh
absolutely it wouldn't satisfy my pocket
I have to say because it's pretty
expensive so for 150 in a restaurant but
so somebody could go out and buy it
where would you buy stuff like that also
you can buy because a lot of people ask
me as well I came out and where can you
buy all this crazy wall just what you
had last time on the show and we said
it's Akamai Eastern Florida so these are
the people who can actually are they
important mostly of the very unique
waters in this country so you can call a
Brett is this his name I call my Astro
and can you say that
slower aqua my Astro oh okay yeah okay
so and he like aqua maestro yes here we
go okay look my German accent my
and again believe me I just wanted to
bait you I wanted to make sure thank you
so aqua maestro ekkuva maestro in
florida and you will find them right
away last time and I will talk to Brent
again last time they gave actually ten
percent off for everybody who mentioned
your mom sounds podcast what yes so
because they had so many inquiries
suddenly for his guild okay so that was
kind of cool and I think this is a nice
thing and for shewbread we'll do this
again when you call him up and say hey I
listen to your mom sells podcast and I
heard marketing yeah for sure he will do
something again okay
he's a nice guy yeah that was likes to
hide very interesting can I switch to
the next one here the next next picture
already you can see the hassle fucking
nuts
where this ice books are collecting so
this ship goes out picks up like scoops
up almost like a fisherman is he picking
liked shrimp and just has a boat full of
iceberg yeah and then they take that
back to some factory and correct correct
and then they are deluding at this water
obviously into the bottle that's so it
really has never touched anything nope
trust ice books and the glass that's
wild man
and then our mouth now yeah that's that
is why it's a fun product yeah like this
and they won because I told you I was
just Russell easily in suave Albertville
body valve as well by the iceberg water
and they just want the in China was a
big water competition and they was just
like the silver medal for taste and then
they won the gold medal for the the
product in general oh the presentation
the presentation is awesome yeah that's
outstanding yeah I think so too and
that's I have to say that's like a lot
of people at my restaurant they're
obviously going in the water many and
they see this beautiful bottle and they
say like do not watch page I want to
drop 150 bucks for water yeah why not
why not experience some people driving a
Lamborghini yeah tool to the gym or to
hot yoga and how we rolling now yeah
Stace so what's what's this next one so
the next one I was very surprised when I
heard about this there Chuck Norris has
a water come on this is the official
Chuck Norris water sea force from Texas
from his privately owned ranch really
yes he has a water and as he was by yes
I reached out to them and they were so
happy to give me some products and said
like hey that's so cool what you're
doing so I did already a video on
YouTube about the taste profile of
cforce and I thought it would be a fun
thing to bring it here to the show not
today because I'm a big Chuck Norris fan
I have to admit this I think he's he's
cool and crazy and so I went to the
homepage as well and they're saying so
Chuck Norris heard that you guys are
thirsty and so he punched the grounds
and made the earth cry yes therefore we
get some water now so it's mothers earth
tears hey man I mean I'm willing to give
her my shot Chuck Norris can try any
chores but isn't a seasonal spring water
and I love this and they're very proud
about this they are saying no we are not
purify anything we want minerals TDS is
run 300 on this water so okay that's so
that's pretty pretty good stable that's
some mineral yeah yes by US law this is
actually mineral water considered
everything right 250 TDS means it's a
mineral water okay so this is considered
to be a mineral spring water from Texas
cforce hmm let's see let's give it a
shot
Cheers mm-hmm
it definitely tastes different oh yeah
from the from the small body yeah I
think so too I'd has a little sweetness
to it I think hmm
I'm not I don't know I'm not that into
it you're not into a Chuck Norris ow I
mean I'm in or I don't know what it is
about it it's like it's almost like it's
just under the taste I'm supposed to be
tasting or just over something that's
supposed to be masked I don't know it's
like it's like it's very so you feel
maybe because the name Chuck Norris on
it you feel something powerful maybe a
Vichy or Roy or something like this that
sounds like outrageous and taste I
thought I just had different
expectations maybe that's it and that
might be what it is as well oh the
tedious that's 300 again I think it's a
good product obviously it's not so
unique then maybe this four bodies story
or the skill of what we had last time we
change shapes into milk when you're
shaking the bottle it doesn't have
something so extremely unique obviously
also you know what it is also is that I
think I mean without being as familiar
with waters as you are when you said 300
and that this would be considered
mineral water I think my brain was also
like oh no it's gonna have a taste to it
like very subdued okay so that make
sense yeah I didn't taste I don't really
taste much with it yeah yeah but it was
for me interesting to see that Chuck
Norris has that's very important yeah
and I wanted to test that out and it was
like a neat interest imagine trying to
get into the water game like trying to
get into bottled water seems like maybe
should create a you mum's house yeah I
mean like yeah that market before real
all the mummies for all the people who
wearing their jeans what would be our
game plan I mean what source are we
gonna tap oh I have a lot of connection
there yeah that is actually easy for me
okay the marketing though right because
I have a brand of spots called Beverly
Hills 9800 that's right so and it was
last week on the Jimmy Fallon show
that's very okay Jimmy Fallon taste and
you can see it on YouTube right now 2
Chainz taste it with Jimmy Fallon 9 h2o
on the show and and it was a blind taste
test new york tap the famous new york
tab what
considered to be one of the best tap
waters in the States versus nine way h2o
and it's a very funny video it is oh my
god
so Jimmy Fallon is like looking at this
two glasses and tasting the first class
and realized holy shit that is so bad
yeah this has to be tapped and it was
New York tap and he's like and he filled
almost like embarrassed and he said like
I love the city I am being grown up here
New York but this is outrageous like
that water's just no way I'm gonna drink
this really 2 Chainz said right away I
don't think I don't drink tap that's not
my style that's not how I roll yeah I
don't drink tap and then they tasted 9
h2o and Jimmy Fallon into the camera
like oh la la this is expensive shit oh
right that was good
it was a funny very funny your water's
available everywhere yeah not really
everywhere right now because it's a very
small production water as well and
Beverly designer which was actually sold
out right now right after the Jimmy
Fallon show obviously we saw hot right
away you have be thrilled it's crazy it
was great but we need to produce no
again so it's very tricky and it's not
that easy lot of people always think
already they just open it tap and
they're filling this this no no because
I'm a maniac I'm German I want to be
like crazy and I want to be a control
freak when it comes to us I want to make
sure this water is perfect yeah
so we're sourcing that water from the
San Diego mountains and I'm very kind
I'm very strict about where the sauce is
coming from which plastic which bTW you
were using because I don't want to have
any bpa any chemicals in there
it's a beautiful blue bottle the bottle
what we showcase on the Jimmy Fallon
show is a glass bottle as well I'm very
strict about the glass as well I'm I'm
like a control freak when it comes to
this from equality is the non plus ultra
and I don't want to just give some water
on the mass-market and to just make a
fast buck That's not me
yeah they are for right now ninety-eight
show is sold out but it will definitely
come back when better buy when I feel
the quality is perfect and then I will
released an expansion great that's
awesome I want to get a batch of that
there wasn't plot I'll bring it next
time I won't I will bring it next time
you have one more one more
we're going to Australian aqua life in
this bottle and you
can see already on the label it's a
little bit nap well they sent me a whole
case of water and actually just three
bottles survived the rest was broken Wow
so that's all the time I have this and
obviously my landlord at my apartment
always he like what the hell is this
always while you're getting all this
speed up packages yeah from all around
the world con these days and this is the
fun cool thing about me as a water
sommelier that literally people from
around the world sending me water snow
all the time gotta love that it's really
fascinating there's also your passion oh
yeah it's completely fascinating to
taste all the different mineral waters
from around the world so aqua life has a
TDS of 1300 so this is considered a very
high mineral of water is still version
and this is for me fascinating because
mostly high mineral waters are sparkling
waters but this is are they water
sparkling is because it's more palatable
for minerals no I don't want to say this
but a lot of high mineral content waters
coming with co2 out of the grounds okay
so they're already co2 and aqua life is
still water from entraining you've tried
this yes yeah I tried this already a
thousand thousand three hundred this is
definitely gonna have a flavor yeah it
has to it has a texture has a texture it
has a texture okay oh yeah this is heavy
water yeah this is completely heavy
saying I never X and this for me fascin
you know this is like what I love when i
tasting waters this is so unique and
textures almost if you drink like high
percentage milk or olive oil this is
like the the mouthfeel you know it's
funny your brother's everyone's brain
sends different thoughts i'm
anticipating like my my moment before
was like i was gonna be salty like that
was my my thoughts it's like oil mmm
like salt like smooth like egg mineral
oil like
it's almost like if olive oil was
something you could drink right yeah
it's like a richness to it when you
would close your eyes you would think
you would drink olive oil or you would
drink milk or something yes you would
not think this is water because it's so
heavy in your palette and this is from a
fascinating that's the reason I'm trying
to get them they don't have distribution
right now in the states I'm trying to
get them on my new water menu whatever
lounge at patina next month because I
think it's something so unique I want to
showcase that there's a water for me
again like what my brain is like holy
cow they're so cool that mother nature
gives me something so crazy and so
another three for me by far the most
unique taste oh yeah definitely and the
first ones by far the most unique story
yeah and and also very satisfying yes
yeah yeah and I think it's an
interesting exercise again to see three
still waters this time last time I
brought yes it was amazing and I wanted
to want it to showcase even still water
taste differently and has a different
texture and and can taste completely
different this is so cool yeah man I'm
fascinated and so again if you want to
try people because we got hit up like to
you know the people wanted me to keep
posting about the waters and aqua
maestro yes mm-hmm
bookmarked that you should if you are a
foodie if you love restaurants you come
in Los Angeles go to patina and you
could even possibly meet Martin and and
try something trying to be there on a
daily basis
try last and then put a reminder in your
phone to get Beverly Hills a it's to 900
h2o when it comes back on the market and
watch Bill Nye this will be a fun one
yeah that's a really good one and don't
you have your own site as well Lea show
Martin slash Reiser calm obviously my
own homepage Facebook Instagram is
always Martin resource oh yeah easy to
find me I think and yeah we will
definitely do a post again of the three
waters what be tasty yes yeah there's no
Instagram accounts yes and I had one
more question yes you talked about the
Lambo Jeannie prank yeah that was so fun
and fascinating I was laughing my ass
off and my wife woke even up because I
was watching that episode my bed in the
middle of the night yeah and she was
sleeping already
she's like what the hell is another
thing I was shaking the bed and I was
laughing that hard when you when you it
was so good when you say like holy shit
and you made this voice impression of of
Bertha was brilliant oh yeah but you
were talking about the bottled water
what you had for them and I was like the
whole time getting so when is he telling
me which bottled water
it was a is interested in the u.s. it
was as more of a Oh was it a container
yes here we go I thought so that's what
it was
so a guy I posted it on our on our
Instagram once sent us a case of these
different I think it's called Mir a cool
like water bottles I mean I thought you
know containers like you say hey I am so
that was the thing and so he sent these
to their vacuum-insulated and it keeps
whatever temperature you put it in there
at stays like that for like 35 oh that's
awesome
so they were really cool I thanked him
online I forget his name but I thanked
him on Instagram yeah this wasn't
actually a bottle okay contain because I
was like ego obviously of course was
likes okay which water home which waters
he in his Lamborghini now yeah yeah and
I was looking the whole time and
listening the whole time using did I
missed it now what's going on here I
want this I want to know which what I
ain't in my lambo it's gonna be nothing
but salty swab Rd that language is I
don't know yeah it's a tough language
all the Scandinavian language is almost
like you have a hot potato in your mouth
and you're trying to talk yeah that's
like what what the Danish and Norwegian
each language and you see it written and
I'm like so into me
you just want to drink it dude thank you
so much for coming ashore this was so
cool I love when you do this and let's
do it again any time you want to do
another tasting oh I've been bringing
you always like some fun waters and I
think we should we should do this
definitely again and hopefully Christina
I want mean mommy will be next time yes
well absolutely
let me bring everybody out
this forget it a little song just say
goodbye and that's it Thank You Martin
again for joining us and we'll have this
up again soon
cheese guys really believe it's infected
all of us machine has changed all my two
mommies one Dean's two mommies one day
two mommies London's that's how those
machines we're done t sixteen - sixteen
- sixteen
mommies - mommy's 1d gimmick me head
scratcher I tried your head scratch your
head scratch a head scratch your head
scratch your head scratching
[Music]
dimetapp dimetapp if I kill multiple
people that I actually had this song in
my head over the weekend a
a lot it's not that song I feel like
it's not that bad
I mean you can take some work it needs
work but it's not bad it's perfect
[Music]